Imagine a world in which China
was an environmental leader.
That would be a more
hopeful world, wouldn't it?
When we hear about China,
we usually hear about human rights,
trade disputes, toxic pollution.
And I'm not here to dispute the news.
Instead, what I want to do
is share, with you, evidence,
based on personal experience,
of where China is leading.
ClientEarth, the environmental law
organization that I set up,
has a 15-person office in Beijing.
We work as trusted partners
with the Ministry of Environment.
We train judges and we train prosecutors
in environmental prosecutions.
Let me share with you how this all began.
In 2014,
I was invited to Brussels to meet
a group of Chinese officials.
They said they wanted to meet CEOs
of Western environmental groups
because they were looking to encourage
more environmental groups in China.
Shortly after that,
I was invited to Beijing
by the Supreme People's Court,
the highest court in the land.
The judges were working
on regulations for a new law
that would allow
Chinese environmental NGOs
to sue polluting companies,
including those owned by the state.
They were interested in my advice
because of my extensive
environmental litigation experience
in Europe and in America.
They wanted to know, they said,
what it would take to really make
such a system work.
I found myself
in a conference room in Beijing
with three justices of the Supreme Court
and senior officials
of the Ministry of Environment
and the People's Congress,
which is the Chinese parliament.
"Before we get into details," I said,
"I want to compliment you.
It is amazing that you are writing a law
to allow Chinese environmental groups
to sue polluting companies,
including those owned by the state.
This is revolutionary."
(Laughter)
The senior judge said, "Mr. Thornton,
'revolutionary' is a big word for us."
(Laughter)
So we laughed.
And in that human moment,
I realized I could work with these people.
He said, "Consider it a sea change."
So for the next three months or so,
my team and I worked
very closely with the judges,
designing recommendations
for how to make the system really deliver
for citizens enforcing the law.
One of the key provisions
we worked on involved costs.
Now, it costs money to bring
environmental litigation,
and what really kills you is,
if, when you lose, you have to pay
the other side's costs,
as you do in the UK.
We said this was only going to work
for the Chinese environmental groups
if, when they won a case,
they had all of their costs
paid by the polluters,
but when they lost, they would not
have to pay any of the polluters’ costs.
Because, win or lose,
they were asserting the interests
of the public at large.
Three months after that, I found myself
back in a meeting in Beijing;
this time, in the Supreme Court building
just off Tiananmen Square.
I was there with the head
of the EU-China Environment Programme.
We were sitting at a white marble table
that seemed to be 40 feet long.
Across from us were three
Supreme Court judges.
A senior judge began the meeting
by saying that they had accepted
almost all of our recommendations,
including the key recommendation on costs.
So at one stroke,
the Chinese system became friendlier
to citizen environmental groups
trying to enforce the law
than many countries.
The senior judge then said,
"What do you want to do next for China?"
Now on my prior trip,
I had learned that the Chinese
had just appointed
1,000 environment court judges.
Now environment judges, specialists,
are rare around the world.
In Europe, for example,
there's just a handful in Scandinavia.
Their idea was that, by appointing
all of these specialist judges,
they would hear a vast volume of cases
and raise the quality of the rule of law
for the environment in China quickly.
"So," I said, "you might want
to train those judges."
They then asked us to train the judges.
But I had never trained
a judge in my life.
So I said, “Where shall we start?”
"With us," he said.
"With the Supreme Court?"
"Yes."
"But what do you want to learn?"
"Well," he said, "we want you to come back
and give us a seminar
on climate litigation,
because you're an expert in that."
I said, "Gladly, but what's the thought
behind your request?"
And he said,
“We want to know the best
climate change cases in the world,
because we want to decide
some of the best climate change cases
here in China."
Now I can assure you that I had never
had such a conversation
with the Supreme Court in Washington --
(Laughter)
or even London or Paris.
Certainly nowhere other than Beijing.
So we teamed up with the head
of the EU-China Environment Programme
to create a ClientEarth office in Beijing.
He then organized this training seminar
for the Supreme Court,
where we discussed trends
in climate litigation around the world.
He then organized training sessions
for all of those specialist
environment court judges.
Now more such judges have been
appointed in the meantime,
and as of today,
we've trained more than 1,500
of these judges.
(Applause)
About a year after we started
training the judges,
a prosecutor came to our office and said,
"In that law that you helped write,
we, the prosecutors, got the right to sue
the Chinese government
on behalf of the people,
for environmental matters,
and we've never had the right
to sue the government before."
ClientEarth, on the other hand,
sues governments all the time.
(Laughter)
So they were asking us
to share with them
our experience of suing governments.
This was the Chinese federal prosecutors
asking us to train them
to sue the Chinese government.
(Laughter)
It is the most amazing request
I've ever had.
(Laughter)
So, of course, we started
working with them.
We've now trained over 1,200 prosecutors
in how to bring environmental cases.
(Applause)
A few months ago, (Laughs)
we got a letter hand-delivered
from the prosecutors
to our Beijing office.
Now what I'm told
by my friends in Beijing,
ordinarily, the last thing
in life you want to get
is a letter from the prosecutors.
This, however, was a thank-you note,
and what it said was "Thank you
for your cooperation with us.
As a result of cooperating with you,
we have brought, in 2020 alone,
over 80,000 environmental cases."
Audience: Whoa.
(Applause)
80,000 cases, and the majority
of those cases
were brought against
government departments.
Now, the prosecutors have set up bureaus
all over the country
to keep pushing out this level of cases
to raise compliance standards
throughout the country.
Now if this isn't a revolution,
it's certainly a sea change.
(Laughter)
Now, whenever I talk about China,
I'm always asked about coal.
China burns more coal
than any other country.
We're working on that.
Following the money,
we've been working, for some years,
with the largest banks
and financial institutions in China.
The argument we've been making
is that coal is simply a bad
investment for them to make.
Recently, we had
a two-day seminar in Beijing
for these institutions,
and it was very heartening to see
that that argument
that coal is a bad investment
has now been internalized
by these institutions
and taken into their own thinking.
When it comes to enforcement,
the prosecutors have a new,
fantastic opportunity.
Recently, a government audit
found that many of the new
coal-fired power stations
authorized in recent times in China
were authorized illegally
by provincial officials
who wanted to boost their balance sheet.
Because these were illegally authorized,
they are a perfect enforcement target.
Now, another major problem
is all of the coal-fired power stations
that Chinese companies
have been planning to build
outside China, in Belt and Road
development countries.
So we've been working,
alongside many others,
with the Ministry of Environment,
to try and figure out how you stop
all of those coal-fired power stations
in the pipeline.
And what is wonderful news
is that, in September 2021,
President Xi Jinping,
at the UN General Assembly,
announced that China
would not fund or build
any more coal-fired
power stations outside China.
(Applause)
We also have reason to believe --
and good reason, I think --
that China’s own emissions
will hit their peaking plateau soon
and then will seriously
decline before 2030.
Now, does more need to be done in China?
Certainly -- a lot more, and faster,
just like in every other country.
But what I've found heartening
are all of these changes to the system
that they've been making in recent years.
All of these environment court judges,
the tens of thousands of cases,
many of them against
government departments;
the Ministry of Environment
getting enhanced powers;
the largest banks
and financial institutions
realizing that coal is a bad investment;
the president promising
no more coal outside China.
We work in many countries
around the world,
but I have never seen
the intense focus on systemic change
moving a country towards
environmental improvements
as I've seen in China.
I'd like to think that I have
given you reasons for hope.
China has certainly given me hope.
Thank you.
(Cheers and applause)